all right so it's not like there isn't
enough comparisons to Captain Planet
starting off with water earth fire wind
at a unit with good heart by you powers
combined I am The Painted Lady yeah now
we have this pollution thing which of
course you're just thinking like I just
watched sea captain pollution rise that
my girl
Oh now gaze Bluto with a scar on his
face instead so okay so we have this
episode called the faded lady which I
guess it it's good because of the ending
which sir clearly states look you
shouldn't rely on you know sir these
magical elements to come in and just
save the day you have to sort of pull
your way yet to do something but at the
same time they're doing this after a
magic element came in and saved the day
or the real magic element comes in
layers as things does absolutely nothing
in the end leave so it's but wait a
second the magical element was saved by
them actually doing something okay
so the idea is that the painted lady was
like sir like the river spirit or
something like that my screen engaged
okay it's near to the way it's been no
way it's I I don't know if they're
intentionally lifting anything from
spirit away but that's the first thing I
thought was that polluted by this fear
yeah but you're cleaning it up the
spirit good lick okay
dog so okay what that makes a little bit
more sense so that by making it so dingy
fluid to begin with maybe the elements
that could help them you know can't stay
alive or can be stronger at the very of
use really didn't pick up on them no I
really did I was just like well what the
hell this was she doing there at the end
I'm like oh okay so so now now that may
grants so much shit all over her and she
can do anything q so okay so that makes
a little bit more sense um but this
whole I mean also remember this whole
universe has nature spirits everywhere
which is actually important when you get
near the end of it so I think just it
was a nice way to also
find the viewers that yeah there are
nature spirits out there and they may be
tired of getting crept upon and they may
help you out if you know I saw at the
very end by the way cuz she comes she
says thank you watch my I said yeah oh
yeah I said you did absolutely nothing
what the hell I saw you open your mouth
and then closed down say okay so that's
either gonna come in later I'm making a
jackass of myself you're gonna let me
make a jag as a myself on video it well
if you're talking about does this
painted lady come in later I don't think
so no no but like no like you're just
waiting for me to say oh oh he didn't
care to that actually the spirit was
brought back by cleaning the river you
wanna wait until I could say that video
I was giving you time to come to that
conclusion yourself oh wow you're oh
wise uncle you're us you must come to
this conclusion notice how you you you I
have been gel we were recording then you
could teach me the way show me the
living I couldn't appear to be an ass
myself so but no I did not I did not
realize that if I went back to the
opening um uh narrow I thought you were
just more talking about what was the
point of that episode I didn't well I
didn't realize you didn't get that
connection at all I just thought you
were gonna say was you liar oh no if you
wanted to embarrass myself that video I
thought you were gonna say was a filler
episode in which case I was gonna argue
it no I I don't see white Lea's but not
not entirely
I mean it's we had the episode before
where you know he's in the school with
the kids and he's trying to help them
out and show them hey you know you can
be a little rebellious you can be this
and that you can be kids it's you know
find that way find that creative way and
here is pushing a little further saying
look yes we can help out here and there
but ultimately the responsibility is
yours and the power is
but what I and again I do question it a
touch because like I said they did come
in they did they were the ones that
destroyed the factory and I hate to go
Fox News but you could argue a little
bit like in capital as you know like it
and well wait a minute good I don't know
I need it's still bad guy still fire
nation and such um and obviously a very
pro environment which it you know we've
got nothing against that at all
oh well I think there's something else
here I mean maybe I'm wrong in this
correct me if I'm wrong but they're
still in the Fire Nation so this is
another example twice in a row which I
think is useful which is saying there
are perfectly reasonable good people in
the Fire Nation it's just this is a
really crappy regime running the show
hmm um which i think is important i
think it's part of this this journey
they're making through the fire nation
where they're kind of realizing not
everything is as it seems that you know
what are we going to do in the end
because you know we can say yeah we can
kill a bunch of people and bring the
fire nation down but the same time this
is like will there be collateral damage
are there other ways around this you
know at the same time at the very end
you know it's revealed that it's Katara
as the The Painted Lady and appraises
it's a wonder bender we don't like your
kind around here by law hope you turn so
it's we're gonna go but then they turn
back so quickly and I'm like okay thanks
again nobody's like this if you like the
citizens of Springfield on the sensor
yeah every others like it is like okay
she hopes you on that factor would still
be here she's right and I don't come on
the crazy guys reach for everybody so
it's a little bit crazy dude yeah but no
we thought the same thing I said we both
thought the joke was doing one night I
thought that it was going to be every
time he ducks and comes out there
actually was another brother there but
it's really just a crazy guy that's it
no I you up to
nope I thought the joke was gonna be
he's like no that sounds like my other
brother like he's he's brought in a
third brother now that he has in Port
Regan and I thought they were gonna be
like oh yeah right you know you're all
just a guy and there actually is some
other person that actually is his
brother that is on the third one so he
said that maybe he's a twin but maybe
actually is perfectly normal like
there's there's a couple things you
could do with that Joe guy I think maybe
I was getting like too cerebral and they
were just like no we'll just throw a
joke about you know I think he's crazy
yeah but cut that sorry punch line but
yeah you know not that doesn't ruin
anything um so yeah I mean I don't know
if it necessary called a filler episode
because again you're sort of conflicting
whether or not you do want to all be
really people in this nation but how
there's very fluid is the extent and
where do you stop and help the little
people what's that what's the big
picture what's the smaller picture and
you draw the line and it is a necessary
episode and there's very few when I say
it's slightly a filler episode I mean it
in the sunset there were very few if any
true filler episodes so but there is
some that seem a little more filler ish
maybe than others and while I think this
is a necessary episode there may be
elements of this that you could have
found a way to shoehorn into other
episodes you may not have absolutely
needed this but I still really enjoyed
it um it was a great I'll say this too
it was a great Katara moment I love them
all when she stands up to Sokka and says
no I'm gonna go help these people you
know and then Sokka is that great line
afterwards or he's like fine I'm coming
with you and you know it she's been kind
of going along with these plans lately
and it was a nice moment for her just
just sort of stand up and it taps into
her character because they made her the
healer which she wants to conquer it
would have been totally a Motty role of
just this character sucks um you know
hard um and instead that I think
episodes like this show her standing up
and saying no I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna help this town I'm gonna heal
these people and as long as I think kind
of plays out later near the end you know
their desire to help I think you could
argue manifests itself you know in the
final episodes yeah you could read a
little bit more and this is where I I
kinda have a problem I kind of don't
alright don't know if I really have a
problem with it which is you know sort
of the big picture small picture I mean
Sokka whoever I was don't rob I'm like
psycho surrounding me a lot of be at
this episode like you know come on we
got the schedule this weekend plus five
minutes behind come on come on oh well
baby we can do it man we can combine
eating and going to the toilet at the
same time it is I'm gonna play don't you
try better on a set once actually I like
it it's like oh my god this is me oh
very clever but because of that I really
identified with him when he's saying
look here's this big picture we're a day
behind were a couple days behind we need
to get going this is the bigger picture
this is what we're doing this for
instead we're going to stay behind
another day to help these people which
on the one hand ensure that is helping
out but if they're all going to be blown
to bits anyway or they're all going to
be destroyed then what is to stop those
people those soldiers from going back
and not till in the Fire Nation hey we
just saw this woman who could like
Earthbend a water but maybe is the
avatar and drag you know we don't know
if they're gonna keep quiet about this
very unlikely they're gonna keep quiet
so I'm kind of on the fence on this one
because I don't know I guess we sort of
assumed that they don't tell anything is
again family show but what kind of
lesson is that really saying or I mean
it's never good to Taylor's dreams like
this is always the right time Lou but
why would I would argue this do you win
the battle but lose the war if they just
simply go in and kill the Fire Lord or
take over the city or whatever you still
have an entire nation indoctrinated in
this crap you know it is it really gonna
solve everything like maybe by setting
themselves up and leading by example
here they're actually planting seeds and
places along the way now could you plant
those seeds afterwards as well though
okay and that's assuming no that's
assuming you can get there in time
because again he's saying the schedule
we're being quick
and we only have whatever this
eight-minute planned when the Eclipse it
which of course I'm sure the guy get
there to get their time obviously but I
mean no actually they don't
oh really yeah it ends on a really dark
note oh wow really they don't make it
there they lose the entire bet no that's
awesome oh but regardless I mean oh but
you know what I'm saying here that hey
here's the big picture and I'm not
saying I'm necessarily right I'm saying
that I'm asking it this is really bad
justified and how should we look at this
episode to get the most out of it
because this is a very drip line issue
the final episode addresses this um I
mean I can't say how without darn
spoilers but I will say this that what
the show seems to be implying and
watching it watching this episode again
now with you I'm realizing how they've
been setting this up out all along which
is kind of clever which is this one
group of people is so focused on
quote-unquote the big picture that
they're actually missing the larger
picture that sometimes it's small things
that build upon each other hmm
that actually may be the answer and it's
not all safe and it's not to say that
you should ignore you know the other
plan entirely but I think what they're
saying is there are other ways to do
things and that the one downfall here is
that the obsession over the one plan the
let's view this as an enemy as an I'm
going to be taken down may not be the
only solution here um so it doesn't
really bother me because to me if you've
got two messages going on hers is a
message of let's help these people from
the inside out you know maybe seeds can
be planted and sokka's is you know let's
take these fuckers out from the top on
down it's a souca or Sokka because
that's been driving me nuts yes it's s
oh isn't it is it basically pronounced
Sokka Sokka Sokka I think I which is
standard it's a minute it's an Imagine I
got yes handed to me why I said like
Sookie's name wrong if I'm even saying
it right now so it's just like I want to
just know if it's good enough Sookie is
a Japanese word for moon so that's one
thing
if it's a Japanese word its SoCal and
maybe some weird pausing because they do
weird things with double letters but it
it depends how you spell if it's an
essay in Sokka you know I'll say this
about this episode I just read that this
is what I realized what justified it it
because what I like is when she says no
I have to go in I have to help these
people as best as I can
I like it isn't just a straight-up
battle I like they still work in the
illusion and Aang hiding under the
boards and I like working all that in
what I would have liked maybe they want
the next episode I don't know is if they
could work in okay we're really behind
schedule then to get to the big peak
picture here's how we're gonna justify
it here's how we're gonna work with that
or work around that so that way they
found a way to sort do both then I could
see a little bit more but I don't even
know I am I after I forgot which episode
I don't even know they're gonna address
the fact that they're behind or
something just coincidentally wants them
for were thought they did but I can't
remember for sure I mean when you watch
a lot of these episodes together they
kind of blend in um but this could very
well be just me empty like look you see
the guy being like you know here's the
big picture but a man come on it you're
right I think that's one thing you're
missing is cuz we know they're gonna get
there on time we know they do get there
on time they don't know that but I think
it's being implied that sock has a bit
out of his mind on this one or so so cuz
of it out of his mind on this one that
he is so obsessed you see this obsession
continue with him you know because he
wants to be part of it maybe it's
justified or or it's justified but
everyone I'm wondering if they open
those what I'm talking about yeah I I
think I think that would be like think
it's being implied that he's being
obsessive and he's probably over
calculating the crap out of this and
they probably have more time than it's
being led on okay well they could make
that a little bit more clear even though
he's eccentric they've shown his ideas
do well I mean what you've learn now is
when you calculate things you always add
like two hours yeah now I double my time
he's probably doing that right now is
what I'm guessing but um it's these two
competing philosophies going on and in
and what they end up doing is just both
of them simultaneously and that's why I
think it worked that's why I think it
works you know the the question is if
you're on the way to do it's kind of a
good samaritan tales like if you're on
the way to do something good do you
ignore something else that you can do
good on the way now i mean even as can
you save everybody this is the old
superman question can you save everybody
can you you know i mean obviously they
can but for whatever reason she decided
that this was gonna be her moment where
she was gonna stand up and do it well
what I like is that she she made a
choice to those pele thing even sorry
says maybe this wasn't the right choice
made this wasn't the smartest thing to
do she started it and she's gonna finish
it I like you know once once she may
have realized that she made a mistake
but when she's committed you know she's
committed yes I would like to emphasize
that a little bit more cuz it was much
more no I'm gonna help these people
because they need my help I would like
more no I made a decision I'm gonna
follow through you know oh that's
another way to fight a war I mean
there's two it's basically these two
philosophies are just colliding and
they'll collide all the way to the very
end that I mean I don't think either one
is necessarily a hundred percent right
or wrong yeah I mean uh stray money get
you it's usually not best to deal with
the experience yeah I mean there's
always going to be a job the one the one
thing this show keeps hammering in again
again is there's always an alternate way
so you know which is good because
considering all the mistakes they make
in the show you know is not everything I
think anyone can figure out is always
going to go according to plan
so I don't know it didn't bother me that
much because I feel it's another way to
fight a war which is go from the ground
up or go from top down one's a
non-violent solution the others a very
violent solution well if they're like I
say if they're emphasizing more and more
that they actually do have more time or
they can justify getting more time to
help the bigger picture I think it works
a little better and I do think there's
enough
knows what he's talking about I felt
very welcome yeah I think he's being way
overly cautious not that very well are
you going to the battle strategies of
this I think he's over calculating it so
um but I think it balances out I mean
like I said it's not just one likes it
it's not one extreme they try to balance
out by saying hey look you can't always
rely on this it's not the greatest
episode on the planet either I mean this
is one of those middle episodes sick of
those collars oh god I hope they don't
stay in this one frog it's like I just
hate the Browns and yellows and crazy I
don't think they know but I know that's
the point of it I know it's supposed to
look mucky and disgusting yeah they
start moving away from it I like the
fire city cap a lot that's one of my
favorite level the fuck the foundry has
only great designs I mean that's why I'm
really excited that they're in the fire
nations but it's like oh you guys see
the slums it's just they're like okay
you know I mean I get it and I know yeah
I mean it yes I did you bring me the
towers bring me the castles it had a few
things that had to do it showed there
other ways it showed there's two
competing philosophies it showed us
again that the Fire Nation is basically
screwing its own people so gave us a
sense that the culture is not all bad
there are perfectly reasonable people
though probably would have been made
better if they didn't turn so quickly at
the end it's like again 24 minutes yeah
damage economic tearing a lot that was a
commentary more on the whole religious
thing of like you know you hoaxed us how
do you know that wasn't like a fiery
vision just a lot of God God would come
down to do all this yeah you know I
think you're talking to a guy can work
through you and through other forces ins
that you know it's like it's it everyone
does their part planting the seeds again
and do things for yourself and I and I
thought it was a great moment for Katara
could kiss ara
um cuz yeah when you make somebody a
healer you better damn well show her
healing somebody and it doesn't always
happen like as there's times where
they're not getting hurt so what and I
like that yes that it's at you know
she's a healer but she isn't always just
like calm I know let me just do this
it's like she's actually like pissed
when she's like a lawyer she's like okay
she's
Warner said something those are rushing
to lay idle filled with her first-aid
kit like you know like those always the
heroes I like Fe I like to hear how they
get really pissed off when they're
civilians are hurt or the people that
are going to protect are damaged and
it's like oh you motherfucker man dang
in particular very similar to Vash the
Stampede from trigun which is that sort
of pacifistic warrior of if you want to
piss them off more than anything involve
civilians and then you will see them get
yes is the anti Man of Steel route uh-oh
we got stop I've met you that like in 5d
once I'm sorry and now it's like I'm
really beating a dead horse I know that
was my fault I'm sorry but not because
anyone who likes Manistee not at all cuz
I hate it but I should really stop
beating a dead horse my apologies I just
for beating a dead joke there I've
apologized Oh Jaden yu-er Zuko all right
for some cash oh so okay so regardless
good episode um I mean I would like need
either of our favors but I think there's
definitely serviceable yeah it does one
needs to do and I think it's got a good
moral overall um so so alright see you
the next one